i
[Música]
a
con el pasar de los años eeuu ha negado
que uno de sus objetivos para quedarse
en afganistán fuera ayudar a las mujeres
a ganar los derechos ellos han dicho que
esto simplemente era una consecuencia de
su presencia pero más allá de cuáles
hayan sido los verdaderos motivos la
realidad es que la la mujer en
afganistán avanzó muchísimo en estas
últimas dos décadas un ejemplo es que en
el 2003 el 6 por ciento de las mujeres
tenían educación secundaria y hoy lo
tienen más de 40 por ciento un 5 por
ciento de ellas tienen acceso a la
universidad y si bien es un número
muchísimo menor comparado con países
vecinos como irán por ejemplo donde el
60% de los universitarios son mujeres si
se puede ver ese progreso a nivel
político por ejemplo donde las mujeres
tienen muchísima mayor representación en
el parlamento el 27 por ciento del
parlamento está ocupado por las mujeres
y tienen iniciativas que han logrado
sacar adelante especialmente a enseñar a
las mujeres a cuáles eran sus derechos
algo que sea y seguramente se irá a
perder en este nuevo gobierno talibán
la constitución marroquí de 2011
estipuló por primera vez en el país la
promoción de la igualdad de género y
aunque lo cierto es que se ha avanzado
mucho en las leyes contra la violencia
de género las mujeres siguen
encontrándose con muchas barreras sobre
todo lo que tiene que ver con el acceso
a los puestos de responsabilidad y poder
y esto mismo se ve reflejado en el
propio gobierno donde de 23 ministros
solamente cuatro son mujeres por otra
parte los colectivos de defensa de
derechos a ponen el foco en la ausencia
de políticas para erradicar una
violencia que afecta mucho a las mujeres
qué es la explotación sexual y de hecho
cada día son más las que a través de las
redes denuncian estas violencias y
aseguran sentirse desprotegidas por el
estado es el caso reciente de la
youtuber yamila saddam alias un vial
fraser quien denunció en un vídeo la
trata de mujeres y niños aquí en
marrakech y responsabilizó al rey dijo
por su inacción acto seguido la youtuber
fue detenida y encarcelada por presunta
difamación y ha ultraje a las
instituciones del estado y ahora la
asociación marroquí de derechos humanos
y otros colectivos feministas piden
supuesta libertad y que se investiguen
los crímenes que denunció en el vídeo
[Música]
guatemala es el país centroamericano más
poblado con un poco más de 17 millones
de habitantes de los cuales las mujeres
representan el 51.2 por ciento mayoría
que no necesariamente se ve reflejada en
una igualdad de oportunidades de acuerdo
a un estudio presentado por el foro
económico mundial guatemala es el país
latinoamericano peor posicionado en
cuanto a la reducción de la brecha de
género los factores que se tomaron en
cuenta para este estudio son la
participación económica la salud los
logros educativos y el empoderamiento
político pese a que se han hecho
esfuerzos por reducir estas
desigualdades con la suscripción de
contratos internacionales
además la creación de leyes a nivel
local la desigualdad se sigue
manifestando en la sociedad guatemalteca
de acuerdo a un informe también
presentado por iniciativa joven la
crisis provocada por la pandemia del
cobi 19 provocó que muchas mujeres
fueran despedidas de sus empleos
remunerados
dando sus niveles de pobreza de
desigualdad desempleo y además la
violencia en contra de ellas
[Música]